tres científicos estaban experimentando
con químicos en un laboratorio y
terminaron infectados por un virus
desconocido es un virus muy poderoso y
contagioso me ayudas a saber cuántas
personas se contagiarán después de nueve
horas y 15 minutos para averiguarlo
necesitamos saber qué tan rápido se
extiende el virus la información con la
que contamos es la siguiente en los
primeros cinco minutos había 27 personas
contagiadas en diez minutos 102 en 15 ya
eran 227 personas y en 20 minutos 402
guau va rapidísimo en la tabla podemos
identificar una te para tiempo
transcurrido y una p para personas
contagiadas entonces qué tenemos que
hacer encontrar la expresión que
relacione los dos datos tiempo y
personas contagiadas analizamos la
información
tomaremos la td el tiempo transcurrido y
la p de personas contagiadas y las
escribiremos en una ecuación de igual a
p si tomamos el último dato de la tabla
te vale 20 y p es igual a 402 pero es
decir que 20 es igual a 402 no es
correcto para buscar la igualdad vamos a
buscar un número que multiplicado por si
mismo se acerque a 402 así que lo que
podemos hacer es multiplicar 20 por 20 y
obtenemos 400 pero nos faltan 2 para que
sea 402 entonces si multiplicamos 20 por
20 y le sumamos 2
el resultado será 402 esto es lo mismo
que 20 al cuadrado más 2 es igual a 400
2 si sustituimos estos datos por las
variables de nuestra expresión
algebraica quedaría de la siguiente
forma t al cuadrado más 2 es igual a p
lo viste
probemos con otro dato de la tabla para
verificar que nuestra expresión sea
correcta y así saber cuántas personas se
contagiarán después de 9 horas y 15
minutos
por ejemplo el 10 10 al cuadrado más 2
es igual a p entonces sería 10 por 10
más 2 es igual a 102 perfecto
encontramos la expresión algebraica que
nos ayudará a conocer el número de
contagios pero entonces que tenemos que
hacer para saber cuántas personas se
contagiarán después de 9 horas y 15
minutos sólo tenemos que sustituir los
datos pero cuidado todo lo hemos
manejado en minutos primero convirtamos
las 9 horas y 15 minutos a minutos una
hora tiene 60 minutos si multiplicamos
60 por 9 porque son nueve horas
obtenemos 540 y le sumamos los 15
minutos que nos faltan así tenemos un
total de 555 minutos
excelente este será el dato que
sustituiremos en la expresión de al
cuadrado más dos es igual a p
así que 555 al cuadrado más 2 es igual a
555 por 555 es igual a 308 mil 25 más 2
tenemos 308.000 27
perfecto así sabemos que de propagarse
el virus con esa rapidez después de 9
horas y 15 minutos habrá 300 8 mil 27
personas contagiadas
que los médicos y científicos se den
prisa y paren el contagio como te diste
cuenta la expresión algebraica nos ayudó
a calcular el número de personas
contagiadas en determinado tiempo si
quisiéramos conocer otro dato sólo
tendríamos que sustituir el valor del
tiempo prueba analizando los datos de
varias tablas para saber si la ecuación
que lo representa escuadra tica o no
éxito